it's our friend emmy eaton
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
honestly being on your show is like
getting the biggest warmest hug it's so
nice
emmy i'm just so amazed by everything
you do i just loved your instagram
because you were interviewing craig
robinson you were doing such an amazing
job you're such an amazing journalist
thank you i saw your comment and i was
i've been looking forward to being on
this when we found out i literally was
like jumping up and down i was so
excited screaming i'm happy on me too i
was so excited to congratulate you on
your beautiful work and be able to say
and i'll see you next week because life
with you and me is just better period
i mean we've been doing this show
together for two years now and guess
what emmy we actually made it to season
three
i'll be back i was going to say and this
time will you come back to new york
please yes okay perfect all right now
back to the news
um
will you please give us our first
headline
yes i will this comes from the magazine
the week a woman in iowa wanted to give
her dad a retirement gift after he
retired from the fire department she
asked fire departments around the
country to send t-shirts she wanted one
from every state she got that and even
more she even got one from afghanistan
she's going to make them all into a
quilt for her dad i think i'm gonna ask
my fire department to give her one uh
[Applause]
it's so special when you get something
like that a gift that means so much you
know after after my mom passed away her
best friend bonnie went into her closet
and took some of her shirts and made me
like some pillows with my mom's shirts
and it's something i treasure so much
you know because the clothes we wear
they're part of us you know and when you
give them and make something else out of
them it's beautiful don't you think emmy
yeah yeah i do too i think it's so
touching and special
all right so you're the best in the
business emmy can i get your take on
another story
yes all right listen to this
netflix has just added a famous show
from japan and it's called old enough
it's a reality show where you get to
watch adorable children run errands
all by themselves oh my gosh and envy
you like that emmy
yes or really
you want to run some errands
yeah i got some dry cleaning you can
pick up okay i mean okay
well now npr reports it's not just an
adorable reality tv a parents around the
world say they send their kids on
errands early to teach them independence
and confidence whether it's getting an
egg from the neighbor's house or running
to the market kids around the world are
getting things
done just like you emmy you get it done
right
yeah yes
what's your favorite kind of errand to
run
um i like doing it because at the store
so like the other day dad let me go up
we were at a restaurant
and dad let me go up and order food all
by myself
and i got to pay for it too
wow
emmy i'm i'm curious what do you think
about this story first of all as a
journalist
and then what do you think about it as a
young woman
well first off i think that's adorable
like three-year-olds and four-year-old
are like going grocery shopping on their
own
so i think that's adorable and as a
journalist i feel like
like i'd be actually it'd be cool to ask
questions to someone who like to one of
the kids who have actually done that i
think that'd be really cool or one of
their parents yeah i agree it's like i
think there's a richer conversation here
because i think we let our used to let
our kids do whatever they wanted and no
eyes on them and now we've kind of
become helicopter parents society and so
we're all shocked by this story but i
think there might be a balance we need
to get back to it like empowering our
kids and letting them you know have
autonomy and do things on their own and
i think we as parents are scared to let
our kids do anything and that's not good
either yeah but there should be a
balance right because as an
eight-year-old i could have run an att
store i was on top of it you know what i
mean i was good
but some kids maybe shouldn't be um you
know driving to walmart pick up
groceries well obviously not before they
have a license right i'm just eight i'm
not like 16. you can't drive when you're
eight here that's right that's right but
i i i really like this story and i think
it's interesting i think
um
we should
we should find out what our kids are
capable of
and support them
and i'm talking to you emmy eaton who is
a journalist on the beat and really
doing extraordinary things so look at
what people are capable of
you're capable of anything thank you
it's true
so i just love this and i love you and
me so much i love you guys too
we love
[Applause]
and i'm gonna give you guys the biggest
hug in the world well you can call that
a date emmy e10
[Music]
you